sommes mercredi il est 6 heures du matin
nous sommes le 26 septembre
et c'est quelque chose que j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à intégrer puisque c'est
complètement faux puisque occupé du tout
en a un petit peu d'avancé parce que il
ya le globe ce qui arrivé voilà
d'ailleurs comment tu as trouvé le
spectacle à l'olympia pression alors que
les banques doivent placer mais oui
c'est ça se trouve je suis né j'ai re
journée a vraiment était en train de
petits matchs parce que d'un temps de
bien asseoir cette chaîne
oui voilà c'est au mensonge d'état
mesdames et messieurs bonjour je vous
présente me code que vous connaissez
forcément puisque c'est pas la première
fois qu'on se voit et c'est pas pour la
femme vous voyez si vous le connaissez
pas sa chaîne étant barre d'infos comme
disent les anciens en description comme
je dis moi
les nouveau nés nous chercher un nouvel
ancien de youtube je pourrais basse le
lieu aller chez lui le tuer parce qu on
touche y aller mais ça me faire [ __ ]
et aujourd'hui donc mis quatre communes
est ce possible d'un hacking tous à ma
charge me suis dit quand j'ai reçu cette
boîte là qui s'appelle la viking box lee
[ __ ] je sais pas pourquoi ça me fait
penser à me code alors une menace
ça me paraît une on regarde la up
lincoln tu vois direct foot ouais c'est
pas comme il y avait un espèce de truc
l'algorithme ouais tu vois j'ai
l'impression que on doit croire taper le
code pour que pour pouvoir ouvrir la
boîte et c'est un peu comme ça tu t'es
fait connaître sur youtube d'ailleurs en
faisant ça fait un peu code de j'ai pas
de téléphone tu voi avec 2 ouais c'est
ça en plus en cas de données tu vois ce
que je veux dire donc je les gelées pas
testé pour l'instant parce que j'ai un
petit peu étudié ici nous avons un petit
mouvement
on voudrait que ça ouvre là on voit bien
que les encoches empêche l'ouverture
donc qu'il faudrait juste content donc
donc je pense vraiment que l'encoche
doivent plus être dans ce truc
évidemment pour complice au lycée et
pour bouger les encoches on voit bien
que l'ebit qui nous embête un petit peu
donc donc oui donc voilà donc je pense
que tu apportes de 3 minutes et puis
c'est réglé et puis c'est arrivé tu
crois et je pense que les locales sur ce
niveau là ça ouais en fait tu vois si tu
regardes la découpe de la boîte mail à
l'appui ouais et donc je me dis ben en
fait ce qu'on veut c'est tirer tout
l'ensemble comorien et donc que ça se
soit soit barré par la soie barré par
l'hadopi lauquet quoi et pour les
remettre tous droits il faut mettre les
vies dans une certaine
bah ouais disons que la regarde on peut
faire bouger à cause des bills a conclu
la wii
ouais ok mais qui a bougé et là aussi ok
alors qu'à regarder ouais là on voit que
ça s'il a une position ici ou là on
pourrait pousser là est donc libéré et
tu vois libériens ces deux là sans flash
et l'un l'autre de manas oui c'est ça
quand y en a un qui bouge l'autre non
c'est ça c'est donc l'une lie dans une
grande configuration qui passe les mines
on va s'appliquer
je peux je crois que celle appliquée la
kiné bloquer tout à l'heure quand
l'habit était dedans depuis l'arrivée à
bouger je pense qu'au début et du cou et
du coup tu vois la nutrition amovible il
est amovible tout à fait parce que ce
serait pas dans le dos rond face à trois
ans alors regardez un autre truc aussi
ces deux trous là ils sont connectés
regarde toi là la petite bille qui est
là à les connecter à ses seins trop et
ça c'est pas un trou et ce bout de bois
là
sans que ce genre de boîte oh oui c'est
ça a changé de sens ce serait sympa si
vous voyez bien mais là vous voyez là
c'est plein là c'est libre et si je
bouge comme ça maintenant là c'est plein
et la céline forcément dès qu'on aura
mis mme biya un endroit où on peut plus
faire le déplacement
voilà ce que je préconise moi quand je
pense à comme c'est ici qu'elle plus de
trous de classe je me dis il faut
essayer d'envoyer un maximum de bill
éjecté vers là tu vois ce que je veux
dire et non loin de la pression oui la
haine profonde obtenir parce que lui là
si je prends celui de droite je me dis
si je mets la bile à jamais celle oui
voilà ça lui suffit même pas là tu vois
ça bloquera l'ouverture donc en fait ça
c'est sa position à lui oui donc
clairement dans cette position il peut
pas voir chaque de biche changé voilà
donc en fait foi je les gect voit ce que
veut dire fois il faut lui faire ami
wayne je pense qu'il faut les injecter
au plus vers la gauche donc l'ami
celle du banh ben cette baisse estime la
bielle l'empêchent de tourner là on a
des consignes récurrente de l'eau
liquide
attention seulement parce que les gens
j'aime à prévenir qu'il obstrue tout
nerfs peut-être même d'ici vous voyez
pas hyper bien les planches vous faire
des gros plans bien joli bien stylé que
je mettrais sur l'île étaient appelés
sur instagram
on est alors même que vous retrouvez
dans la description ainsi que marquer
ici ainsi que ici est extrêmement
pratique
je vous attends qu un bel instant précis
que je ne joue m aussi d'un stade dé
nicollier une idée on attend en
rempotant ps à ce point j'ai trouvé ça
beaucoup gagnent la note peut pas parce
que c est cette manière je sais que si
tu n'es pas le jeu c'est de faire comme
samedi c'est à dire essayer de ramener
cette villa vert et rouge par exemple
peut-être commencer par celle là je ne
sais pas si c'est pour l'instant je n'ai
pas résolu non que je l'apprécié j'étais
attendu famille revient ça mais parce
qu'en croyant sache beaucoup j'ai rien
besoin de prouver voilà le nom suffit
oui et non il faudrait qu'il soit comme
ça
ces gens mais c'est vraiment sympa mais
il ya beaucoup taux qui se cumulent en
fait ouais oui ça c'est qu'en fait
chaque truc implique mais c'est comme
quand toi tu fais des lignes de code
vous avez que l'application qui a dans
mon spectacle scénique note d'ailleurs
qu'il le fait qu'il la connaît et c'est
comme quand tu fais des lignes de codes
du cirque un moment donné si tu touches
quelque chose les implications elles
vont être partout mais là c'est un peu
pareil les dépendances parce que là
typiquement ça j'aimerais le faire
tourner qui ça je suis là alors lui pour
faire tourner moi je dirais que libérer
ni à gauche par un jeu direct
on est à peu près de direct lui du coup
elle faudrait la [ __ ] là mais je me
dis quand reviendras tu en six mois je
reprends un peu les issues pour voir
mais quel coup je me dis que lui
faudrait chargé ici juste pour que je
puisse libérer celui-là du coup mettre
cette ville à revenir là et envoyez lui
là ce qui fait qu'elle l'a le bourgeois
tu sais faire des dessins ans peut le
mettre dans le trou ce qui fait qu riche
peut mettre ça et là je peux
terrassement dont la place à gauche
ok on déjà c'était sa faute devant moi
ces arrivées vont maintenant qu il est
il est tranquille on peut lire fine et
une bille de plus et du coup je me dis
quoi qu'il arrive
j'aime tant qu'il est là je me dis que
quoi qu'il arrive il faudra qu'il soit
comme ça à la fin pour qu'on puisse
ouvrir regarde siège moi je regarde
toujours l'encoche comment fera contre
la m au final elle pour prendre une de
plus en fait donc elle pourra en prendre
même si celle ci le plus oui parce que
sinon ça pourrait fans en ont deux ou
trois noms je pense que tu as non mais
on aurait déjà ouvrir l'art il a ensuite
eu la prune la regarder elles passeront
pas dit si elle s'y met un peu de bois
il ya place pour convaincre ou en fait
je peux pas voir un show que tu
reviennes pour moi je trouve que 2002
mais je sais même pas si on peut envoyer
la deuxième si elle va partir dans les
comptes le contre cette merde où il
attend c'était trop de cheveux pourquoi
on changerait pas de place excellent en
question jean jacques essayons
c'est pas bien là comme ça c'est mieux
c'est beaucoup je comprends que tu
voyais rien dit mais tu vois en fait
elle a vraiment un bout de bois ici
entre les deux tout est là je sais pas
si ça va pas frotter bloqué les entrées
disons oui nous nous attendons à une de
plus j'ai l'impression d'être perceval
et karadoc mettons une allez mettons une
bille est ce que vous savez jouer à la
bille du viking
non alors on comprend des billes les
mêmes prix très fortes à camelot c'est
une fausse réponse
et c est ce que ces faits il a été pris
en vue de s'effacer cru la caméra était
là
si je fais une rotation faut que je me
libère de cela exact mais pour retaper
sur toute la mais pour retaper celui là
il faudrait renvoyer cette villa ici est
celle là est celle là qui peut pas
passer là parce qu'il est bloqué par
cela du coup mon cours et fait jaillir
la chaise du produit tout de la triche
c'est juste le truc et du paf on
pourrait faire ça maintenant laissez moi
maintenant les chocs septiques je sais
plus ce que tu voulais faire mais
j'étais libéré suis là en face c'était
pour et oui si donc tu veut l'ouvrir si
tu veux le bouger lui remettant tu peux
le bouchaoui si c'est oui c'est ça donc
du coup fallait faire tac tac tac tac je
crois ensuite la wii d'accord que tu
voulais donc là on a trois billes et il
est dans sa bonne position finale donc
quand vous avez lui les réseaux ni vous
dire ça surtout que maintenant il reste
que trois billes ça me paraît grave
jouable en fait en fait je pense que la
grosse partie on vient de la faire un
peu 500 rands break ce qui fait que lui
chercher sa position finale ça devrait
être celle ci puisque ces pré rapport à
l'encore est toujours en plus si on peut
lui faire une bise est cool j'attends
mais je me demande si on n'a pas
quasiment fini si je fais lui dédiant sa
position finale ainsi les comme ça oui
je pense pour récupérer donc récupérer
la dernière voilà ça
ça à temps et après si lui je le mets la
regarde si mm besoin de ça il faut pas
juste de refuser cette vigne abc tard m
ainsi carrément le trot raison est-ce
que là on n'est pas bon là on a tous
dans le bon sens ok maintenant je veux
comprendre en vrai c'est bon en vrai
c'est bon il ya plus à toucher à cet
espace central
j'étais laisse réfléchir apportant à
comment on ouvre à la fois j'ai juste de
voir ce qui s'est passé au mais oui
effectivement
alors je croyais que ça le faisait au
dos c'était la partie bloquante en fait
et voilà
ouais bah oui d'accord ok c'est juste
cette petite partie là et après il ya la
viking box et quoi tu vois c'est joli ok
en fait c'est vraiment la partie de
l'otan qui exact qui coulissent trop
bien je trouve ça trop stylé comme ceux
ci comme petit casse tête souhaitent qgc
quoi je te pose la question on a mis
combien de temps on a pas si longtemps
que ça le fait rire a franchement banon
ça c'est ça me parle et rit semble aussi
tête en munich
ouais on y aura peu de coupons vrai
non mais trop cool je ne savais pas si
on est les galères et ou pas je connais
même pas son niveau de difficulté je le
trouvais juste très drôle non mais
vraiment c'est en fait l'impression de
faire un jeu genre voyez ça ça me
rappelle des jeux pour enfants tu veux
te l'offre est tu fais gagner était
abonné sur un store c'est une vraie pro
carrément en fait je trouve super il
fera partie des boîtes que j'ai préféré
ouvrir parce que j'aime bien le système
mais je sais que je me resservir est
plus tellement de celle ci ouais non
m'écoute j'accepte avec grand plaisir
donc c'est un honneur non plus c'est un
c'est un bel objet bah oui et puis et
puis veux tu sais j'avais un côté un peu
steampunk et où j'aime bien mais ça fait
vraiment j'aime en fait tu m'as donné
envie de refaire l'évolution des noirs
tous là et oui je meurs dans vie de
d'essayer ah oui c'est clair que je même
juste là devant toi en fait je vous
voyez passer hors champ médias si casten
exemple très amis c'est tout ce que vous
avez vu ces dernières savent attirer
caverne d'ali baba
non mais il trop sympa mais j'ai dû
revoir ce qu'il ya derrière rossi et
fermerait la porte et faut que tu te
libères de la porte jeune
est-ce que tu le fais gagner à t as beau
sur un style où vous suivez mitad sur ce
lien les services it la description si
vous voyez tous merci mon pote
merci à toi fabien merci on se revoit
très bientôt à l'olympia parce que pour
eux c'est passé mais pour dans la vraie
vie c'est pas dans la vase y est pour
nous vous vous pouvez me voir en
spectacle par chez vous directement vous
allez les liens de la tournée enfin vous
allez le lien vers mon site où il ya la
carte interactive de la tournée
directement en cliquant ici vous pouvez
vous abonner la chaîne de vicodin
cliquant là vous pouvez vous abonner à
ma chaîne ici vous avez la vidéo du
casse-tête de la semaine dernière à
savoir l'une des pièces du jeu d'échecs
à très bientôt c'était me code non salut